[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Security
Health Analytics
is a native scanner in
Security Command Center.
It assesses the overall
security state and activity
of your virtual machines,
containers, network, storage,
and identity and access
management policies.
The built-in capabilities
in the standard edition
includes scans for high
severity misconfigurations
such as open storage buckets.
Using the premium edition of
Security Health Analytics,
you gain access to scans for
many more potential security
issues such as API keys
that need to be rotated.
In addition, you get compliance
monitoring and security posture
management against
standards and frameworks
such as PCI DSS, CIS GCP 1.0,
[INAUDIBLE],, and ISO 27001.
To enable Security
Health Analytics,
you must have the Security
Center Admin Editor
role in Cloud IAM.
When you're finished
adding roles, click Save.
Then use the navigation window
to head to Security Command
Center.
When you arrive, click
on Add Security Sources.
Use the toggle to enable
Security Health Analytics
if it is not already.
Then scroll down and click Save.
Security Health analytics
scans can take up to 12 hours
to complete on the first run.
After this initial run, it
will scan your resources
twice daily.
The Vulnerabilities Dashboard
in Security Command Center
displays the Security
Health Analytics findings.
If we sort the findings to
show account of active findings
with high severity, you can
see categories such as firewall
rules that allow public access.
Scrolling a bit further, we
can see additional categories
for things like
Cloud storage buckets
that are publicly accessible,
instances configured
with public IP addresses,
instances with SSL
not being enforced, or resources
where the web UI isn't enabled.
For a full list of
vulnerabilities,
follow the link in
our documentation
in the description below.
Drilling in, you can filter
and view vulnerability findings
in many different
ways, like filtering
to one or more projects
or by characteristics
such as category, severity,
or applicable benchmarks.
Security Health Analytics
can automatically
detect common vulnerabilities
and misconfigurations
across a multitude
of GCP products,
and more categories are
continually being added.
After you filter by the
vulnerabilities that
are important to you,
you can click through
to view detailed information
about the findings.
Let's use the Category
filter to take a look
at the open firewall findings.
Drilling into a
specific finding,
you can see a short
description of the issue,
including the asset affected
and what it was detected by.
Under Attributes, you can
see when the finding was
most recently seen and
when it was first found
and the source URI.
The recommendation tells us
to complete two simple steps
to resolve this finding.
You can easily head to the link,
which takes you to the resource
to fix the issue, in a new tab.
All you need to do is follow the
recommendations and click Save.
Here, I am editing
the firewall rules
to restrict the
range of source IPs
that are allowed connection
to a specific project's
virtual machines.
Congratulations.
You've enabled Security
Health Analytics
and learned how to
respond to its findings.
[MUSIC PLAYING]